when stars are alive they are radiant
burning hydrogen every day is a good day
when you're a star you could imagine
them singing for billions of harmonious
years but eventually they will have a
bad day their fuel is steadily running
out turning into helium and other
elements when the most enormous Stars
run out of fuel they collapse under the
irresistible pull of gravity becoming
black holes matter isn't swallowed into
Oblivion instead it spirals inward
towards the Neal star within the black
hole there it continues to exist even
though light from this matter cannot
escape to the outside it is enveloped in
mystery held prisoner by a gravitational
pull